Watching Thomas Sigfried's video on YouTube, he has proof that cancer is not a genetic disease.
Well, he doesn't have the proof that cancer is not a genetic disease. It's been known forever that cancer is not a genetic disease.
Now, understand there are some genetic components to certain types of cancer.
So, but, you know, so, for instance, anybody here has had colon cancer, most likely you've been screened for this certain gene.
Well, well, maybe not if you have no history of colon cancer or your family, but if you have a history of colon cancer, you're failing to guarantee you they screened you for this gene because there can be a genetic predisposition to colon cancer with a certain type of gene.
You have a couple patients that have that.
So, yeah, cancer is not a genetic disease. It is an acquired disease and it's environmental.
He wrote a book on as cancer as a metabolic disease, and I read that book that came out, I don't know, five, seven, eight, ten years ago.
He's not a doctor, but his studies suggest that cancer spread by glucose.
Well, the only thing I didn't like about his book is that he, he, he's not a practicing physician.
So, matter of fact, his whole idea to starve cancer was everybody with cancer should go on a ketogenic diet.
And he had one, one patient example in the book, who actually had smoldering blood cancer, not a hard cancer.
So, it was, was not even a good example where a ketogenic diet and this person did well and stated remission on a ketogenic diet.
Now, so, the reason what I write about is that every cancer is different and every person's different.
So, he makes these dogmatic statements that I didn't like in his book.
I mean, there's things to learn from everybody.
So, I do try to glean the truth out of everything that's out there.
And he had a lot of good studies and he had a lot of good work in his books.
I'm not knocking his book, but then when you take it to the point that every single person with cancer should be on a ketogenic diet,
and it's always this, and this is what it is, then it starts to go, ugh, it's just a little fishy.
It's like every person, if somebody got helped with chemo, then every single person should be on chemo.
That just doesn't make any sense. Every human being is different.
So, that's why we test for was your cancer mainly driven by glucose as your main cancer mainly driven by glutamine.
That's why we do test that one HIF-1A gene, because if you have that gene defect,
you have a much greater chance of your cancer being driven by glucose and doing a ketogenic diet or a keto-like diet,
or restricted fasting or restricted eating modified fasting can be really good for you.
So, that's why we test the specific foods.